i'm lee eisenberg the author of shopton
ism
well you know the American character I
mean we I think we've got it into our
head now that we are a nation of
shopaholics you know though that we are
all incredibly greedy we don't know our
limits and that's true a lot of us don't
know our limits and you know the the
economic meltdown that we've experienced
last couple years is to a very large
degree because you know our eyes were
bigger than our wallets but I think
that's a mischaracterization in some
ways I think that's too broad a an
indictment of the American people
overall but I also think it's it's
rooted in this very strong conflict that
you know exists and has existed in the
American character you know as as we all
remember from school if not from buying
experience we were really a nation
founded on frugality and waste not was
what not you know the measurement
Franklin credo and and a century or two
in which the character was defined by
not spending money but by abstinence and
then beginning in the 19th century
things began to change in a very
accelerated and radical way global
industrialization brought all kinds of
goods that were increasingly affordable
to more and more people beginning in the
early nineteenth century and you had
these actually not far from this studio
just around the block on the street in
fact these incredible department stores
in the form of Italian pilato's that
started springing up in the early 1900's
we're not only the upper class but
working-class men and women could come
into these fantastic emporia piled high
with goods from all over the world and
and we had never seen anything like that
before and the department store as we as
we came to know it was started so
suddenly there was this beginning of
this tremendous sort of shift that that
that had to happen and I think a
conflict which is on the one hand you
had a very strong sense of you know
puritanical Yankee frugality
colliding head-on with this world this
explosive world of material abundance
and ever-increasing wages and I I think
to a much greater degree than a lot of
current observers give us credit for we
are most of us are still wracked by that
conflict you know it's easy to say that
we spend and spend and spend and again
many people do and they overspend but
for most people that I talk to everyday
people normal people out there there is
still this this pleasure pain principle
at work you know we may spend money
freely and often recklessly but not
without some feeling of anxiety or guilt
and I mean some people don't feel that
but a lot of people do feel that and and
I think what's happening now now that
we're living in very challenging
economic times is that that pendulum is
swinging a little bit back it's not
going all the way back to waste not want
not
although there are anti-consumerist
there out there who would have us do
that but but going swinging back from
what what in the book I call a romantic
form of shopping which is shopping
because we are emotionally satisfied or
aroused by the shopping back to what I
call sort of a classic mode of shopping
which is putting a premium on all kinds
of things such as practicality or
utility or durability getting fair value
for a given price getting quality for a
price a more mindful kind of shopping so
you know I don't suggest as I just said
that we're going to revert into some
kind of a you know a Victorian age of
careful spending but I do think that at
least for the foreseeable future some of
those old values that we thought had you
know gone gone away beginning in the 50s
may may well come back to at least
occupied part of our psyches when we go
into a store
the the canard is the cliche is that
women shop and men buy which is to say
you know men are divided into these two
categories there either grabbing goers
you know the guys who run in where is it
I hate shopping I'm out of here goodbye
or they're classified as weight and
whiners you know when they go out with
their spouse or their partner you we've
all seen them on the Saturday afternoon
sitting there you know solemnly on a
bench if there is a bench in the
department store really grumpy that they
have to you know be forced into into
doing that as opposed to lying on the
couch watching the ESPN on a Saturday
afternoon so so men have been cast as
these characters who hate shopping women
on the other hand have been unfairly
cast as these creatures who were built
to shop you know who can barely tell the
difference between shopping and
entertainment or shopping as an
recreation so one of the things I did in
connection with the book was to go
shopping with a great many men and a
great many women and and what I find is
that yeah most men tend to be a little
more impatient than women but I found a
great many women who liked nothing else
than to grab and go and who really
detested the act of shopping and I found
a lot of men who while they wouldn't
necessarily you know admit to it easily
really did like to shop the the other
interesting thing about men and women is
that women I think have taken the rap
for being shopaholics for being
compulsive buyers and there was a major
study probably the biggest study yet
done on compulsive buying published last
year and it was it was found that there
are proportionately as many males who
qualify as compulsive buyers as as women
but men have have an interesting dodge
you know ask a man who you know acquires
200 digital cameras even though he never
takes a photograph whether he's a
compulsive buyer of digital cameras and
he will say no no I'm not I'm not a I'm
not a Shopaholic I'm a collector and I
think men have been able to hide behind
collecting a little bit more
successfully than women have in terms of
maybe being out of control in terms of
by
either a category of something or
anything and everything you know that
said there are some differences you know
statistically men hate to return things
to stores women return more they buy
more they shot more so they return more
but they also seem to have an easier
psychological time returning to a store
men when you ask them why you know you
brought it home it doesn't work or you
can't figure it out or you you you
bought it with too many features or
buttons or options you can't work it why
don't you just take it back men men or
it's just or it's the thread is coming
out something is wrong where it's the
wrong size men will often not take it
back to the store and if you if you
press them and say well why not well you
know well first of all it means another
trip back to the store which you know
may be overwhelmingly too tedious or
ownerís do but a lot of men really fear
the the the confrontation that almost
never takes place at a store but fear
that there's going to be some kind of a
conflict or a little bit of a conflict
or confrontation and they would just as
soon avoid that now in fact most
retailers or most good retailers make
returning things as hassle-free as
possible because it's far better
business to return something and not
lose a customer for life than to give
somebody a hard time over return of one
object and then you know never see that
person again so so men have all these
fears the other the other group by the
way and it's it's a male and female
group that that has a very high rate of
unwillingness when it comes to returning
things are college students and again
maybe the some of the same reasons they
don't want the confrontation or they're
too slothful or whatever it might be but
they don't return goods either
there the south side has a number of you
know I'll call them tricks but I don't
necessarily mean they're unethical
illegal or really things that we don't
easily see through you know there's a
very very deep art and science to
pricing for example which I you know how
do you set a price for something and
then how do you advertise a price lots
of studies have been done on what kinds
of offers for example are likely to push
us from I don't want it to oh it looks
like a pretty good thing a good deal of
I'll buy it you know if you are
generally a somebody careful with his or
her money if you're kind of a you know
sort of bordering on a cheapskate
studies have found that the mere
insertion of the word only or just in
front of a price will actually tip the
balance in terms of whether a frugal
person will buy something so you know
here's a sign that says five dollars
here's a sign that says only five
dollars or just five dollars that one
word will often make a bit of a
difference another thing that the south
side does quite successfully is to plant
a suggestive suggested reasons for why
something might be useful so you know
the classic one is a hundred and one
uses or you know buy one for a picnic
buy one to keep in the refrigerator buy
one for your car you know you you get a
sense that okay it's pretty good to buy
three of those because I'm gonna get a
lot of you know use out of it a very you
know well-known one and it's ridiculous
you know in terms of both the rhythmic
mathematics and logic is you know three
cans for six dollars whereas you can buy
obviously one can for two dollars but
just the fact that I don't know that the
impression of the three four sort of
moves us away from what our original
intent might have been which is buy one
into another slightly different sort of
cognitive realm so we wind up being
three now none of those things is
necessarily you know wrong I mean it
they probably say more about her
brains work then about anybody's
malevolent intent the the other thing
about the other thing about pricing
maybe one of the more interesting things
I think is that consumers should be
aware of how retailers and Merchants can
can play with three versions of
something three different priced
versions of something and you see this
in a lot of different places but very
often a say a retailer might be offering
three jackets three three down jackets
or something like that and one it has a
lot of features and it's got you know a
lot of down and a lot of zippers and a
fur hood and you know some stuff and
that's $200 you know or whatever it
might be and then the same retailer
might have a stripped-down version of
that for 99 dollars it still has you
know some down it's got enough down to
keep you warm it's got a lot of zippers
there's no fur on the hood and it's you
know your basic model of that jacket and
then then there's a middle one that that
has a little more down than the one on
the bottom and a little less down it
doesn't have fur but it feels pretty
good maybe it comes in some additional
colors and very often what yre tailor is
doing that is not he's very happy to
sell you the expensive one he's very
happy to sell you the cheaper one but
generally speaking what he's doing is
trying to sell you that middle one and
he's probably bought many more of those
middle ones and the reason that tends to
work is that we we reference the value
of that middle one by the ones on the
other the two extremes and because
there's an expensive version in the
store we immediately assume often
rightly that the store has really good
things really quality things and and the
prices to prove it at the same time the
lower the lowest and one is it seems to
be a really good value so it's really
not that high price I can shop in this
store pretty easily so that middle when
we default to the middle one because it
seems like a really you know we're in a
nice place with good stuff but we're not
place that's too expensive for us
because of the cheaper one so that
middle one represents a really good
value in the trade it's called the good
better best strategy but you also see it
in you see it in a lot of different
places you know when times are tough and
if you walk into a coach leather goods
store for example coach is a brilliant
retailer at measuring their prices
against the economic moment and they
know that in times like these people are
not going to be spending many hundreds
of dollars on a handbag by and large we
might spend a bit of money on a change
purse or a small wallet or something
like that so what what a coach will do
and other stores will do is often take a
very expensive bag you know bathe it in
beautiful halogen light so that it
shimmers and and casts in effect a halo
over what is placed around that
expensive bag which are you know smaller
low-priced items that presumably we can
better afford so that that halo effect
often happens in a store you'll see it
and Ralph Lauren a lot where you you
know there's a extraordinarily expensive
leather bag and it's surrounded by other
things that are not necessarily
inexpensive but compared to that bag you
know even a $300 cashmere sweater
seems pretty cheap of course it isn't
for most people but it's it's a way that
that the retailer has a sort of
relieving on some of some of the guilt
that might be attached to buying a
wallet that we don't really need or a
cashmere sweater that's expensive but we
can kind of before
I make the same spending mistake over
and over again and it's and it's a very
inconsistent thing I will go to a fair
amount of trouble to do research on the
most meaningless and inexpensive things
a USB cable or you know twelve triple-a
batteries I mean all these things that
are not going to ruin my family's
finances one way or the other I'll
actually research those but then I will
be totally and erratically spontaneous
when it comes to booking a vacation or a
dinner you know something that's that's
expensive without doing a whole lot of
due diligence and I make that spending
mistake over and over again to the point
at least that you know I haven't broken
the family's piggy bank but from time to
time I you know I test it having said
that I think I'm not a profligate buyer
I think I'm a fairly typical buyer in
that I am given to irrationality and
wildly inconsistent